ich eröffne nun die aussprache und
zuerst hat das wort für die
bundesregierung der minister dr robert
habeck
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren guten morgen und
danke dass ich zum einstieg in der
debatte kurz das wort bekommen kann und
reden kann alleine die schiere zahl und
der umfang der gesetze zeigt was gerade
phase ist was wir in einer zeit leben wo
die energie und die energiesicherung
sicherheitsrelevant für deutschland und
für europa geworden ist mit diesem
gesetzespaket mit diesem ich würde sagen
größten gesetzespaket im energiebereich
der letzten jahre wahrscheinlich
jahrzehnte ziehen wir notwendige und
dringend erforderliche veränderungen
nach die gesetze sind umfänglich das
große eg sorgt dafür dass für die mengen
an energie die wir zur einhaltung der
klimapolitischen beschlüsse der
vergangenheit brauchen auch
bereitstellen können die erneuerbaren
energien gekommen jetzt das überragende
öffentliche interesse und damit auch in
der abwägung von schutzhütten in
vielerlei hinsicht ein vorhang die
eeg-umlage wird mit diesem gesetz finale
abgeschafft mit dem wind auf see gesetzt
würden die ausbauziele offshore auf 30
gigawatt 2030 und dann 70 gerate 2045
festgeschrieben und hoch geschrieben
sodass wir auch industriepolitisch ein
klares signal geben was hier in
deutschland in den nächsten jahren
machen werden und brauchen werden es
gibt ein neues ausschreibungs design zum
ersten mal werden qualitative also auch
die umweltschonende kriterien mit in die
vergabe mit 1 berücksichtigt mit
einbezogen und der ausbau der netze wird
in zukunft genau das finde ich auch ganz
großartig der ausbau der netze wird in
zukunft durch die ausschreibung
ebenfalls von den windkraftparks
betreibern mitfinanziert das wind an
land gesetzt
das wird ein gang gesetzt sorgt für eine
faire und gerechte verteilung und die
möglichkeit von handelsmöglichkeiten
untereinander so dass wir nicht nur
fordern sondern in diesem fall die
länder auch in die pflicht nehmen die
ausbauziele die wir als gemeinsame
kraftanstrengung in deutschland leisten
müssen gemeinsam zu tragen dass ersatz
kraftwerks beschaffungs gesetz gibt uns
in der aktuellen situation die
möglichkeit gas kraftwerke aus dem markt
heraus zu drängen indem wir die reserve
die dafür geschaffen wurde in
notsituationen kohlekraftwerke
hochzufahren in diesem fall nutzen und
das energie sicherungs gesetz schon
einmal in dieser legislaturperiode
angepackt ein 50 jahre altes gesetz ich
weiß noch dass kollege uli kirsch ist ja
andere aufgaben hat und kollegen anderer
stelle geworden ist wie gesagt hat er
hofft dass es nie genutzt wird weil es
so ein scharfes schwert ist aber es
sorgt dafür dass wir es nutzen können
dass viele optionen geschaffen werden
und ich bin dankbar ich bin wirklich
dankbar auch der opposition der unions
opposition dass es gelingt hoffentlich
gelingt vor den sommerferien das arsenal
der möglichkeiten noch einmal zu
erweitern und zu präzisieren
wir sind in einer phase wo wir uns alle
optionen des handelns erhalten müssen
sehr geehrte damen und herren insofern
mit der dankbarkeit
dass das so möglich ist und konstruktiv
möglich ist möchte ich dem ganzen haus
jedenfalls dem haus sind teil des hauses
das konstruktiv gearbeitet hat und ich
glaube ich verrate kein geheimnis nicht
nur konstruktiv sondern bis an die
grenze der nervliche belastbarkeit
gearbeitet hat ein ganz großes
dankeschön aussprechen es war ein großer
kraftakt
kommt ein notwendiger kraftakt und
dieser notwendige kraftakt das kann ich
mir dann doch nicht verkneifen bei aller
freude dass dieses große werk
hoffentlich jetzt gelingt wurde gestern
vom oppositionsführer als
schönwetterpolitik dargestellt
vielleicht mit folgenden anmerkungen
wenn man sich vor eisbergen politik auf
vielen lässt ist das eisberge schmelzen
wenn man aus allen möglichen dingen
aussteigt zurecht aber vergisst dass man
dafür eine infrastruktur aufbauen muss
wenn man klimapolitische beschlüsse
fasst sie aber nicht mit massnahmen
hinterlegt dann lässt man deutschland im
regen stehen und das haben wir
das haben wir in der vergangenheit
erlebt
immer größere abhängigkeit von
russischen fossilen energien mangelnden
diversifizierung nichteinhaltung der
klimapolitischen ziele schleppen naja
zusammengebrochener ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien zerstörung der
solar und in weiten teilen auch der
windindustrie die wir hier in diesem
land schon hatten verlust von
zukunftsfähigen arbeitsplätzen und einem
marktwirtschaftlichen hochlauf für die
zukunft technologien bremsen in europa
kein plan kein überblick aber sagen das
was wir jetzt machen ist
schönwetterpolitik sehr geehrte damen
und herren buchstäblich steht
deutschland im regen hätten wir diese
pakete vor zehn jahren durchgezogen wir
würden ganz anders heute darf und so
dass wir hier machen
dass diese waffen aus deutschland wieder
eine energiepolitische zukunft zu führen
vielen dank
der bundeswirtschaftsminister mit
einleitenden worten zu dieser debatte an
deren ende fünf ländliche abstimmungen
stehen werden unter anderem vier zum
thema erneuerbare energien
und wir werden jetzt hören was die
opposition zu robert habeck ausführungen
sagt andreas jung für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
kolleginnen und kollegen in diesem
speziellen fall auch direktor verbunden
mit einem ganz herzlichen dankeschön für
ihr wirken auf seiten unserer fraktion
minister habeck neben den dringlichen
fragen der energiesicherheit geht es mit
dem oster paket zum ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien heute vormittag um
ein herausragendes projekt dieser
bundesregierung ich frage sie warum sind
sie als wirtschafts und klimaminister
denn eigentlich der einzige minister
dieser bundesregierung der heute auf der
regierungsbank sitzt
ich sage nicht ich lade die
zwischenrufer aus der spd wo ist der
klima kanzler der platz das thema kannst
das ist leer und es ist beispielhaft
nicht nur in diesem parlament das
beispielhaft auch für seine linie in
vielen fragen die frage
frage die vertreter der
der finanzminister spricht von heimat
energie bei diesem thema heute ist es
konkret geworden gerade eben hat die
vertreterin der grünen ingrid nestle
draußen gesagt man könne jetzt nur das
eeg anfassen und nicht auch besser und
was wir form was der bundesrat fordert
nämlich die steuerfreiheit für
pv-anlagen auf den privaten haus der
fordert der bundesrat bringen wir in
einem antrag ein ziel im sub in ihrem
entschließungsantrag sagen sie wir
wollen uns mal prüfen und der
finanzminister ist nicht da der könnte
nämlich handeln und damit vergeben sie
chancen nicht nur dass viele nicht da
sind es wird inhaltlich chancen zu geben
und potenziale liegen gelassen und
herr minister
ich respektiere dass sie sich eben bei
der opposition bedankt haben weil in der
tat es liegt an unserem verzicht auf
formale möglichkeiten des dc dc diese
gesetze heute abschließen können sagt
aber genauso dazu ich bin wirklich der
überzeugung ich sage es ganz ruhig dass
sie eine große chance vertun mit diesem
gesetz nie war die bereitschaft bei
allen beteiligten so groß nie war die
chance wie bei allen beteiligungen bei
allen beteiligten nie war die chance so
kurs in deutschland einen erneuerbaren
konsens über die grenzen von regierung
und opposition zwischen bund und ländern
zu erreichen sie haben eine reise durch
die bundesländer gemacht dann haben sie
es dabei belassen ich hab hier unsere
fraktion hat mehrfach auch unsere
inhaltliche zusammenarbeit angeboten
weil wir die ziele in den ausbau der
anderer warum die beschleunigung
klimaneutralität weil wir die teilen wir
haben unsere inhaltliche bereitschaft
dazu angeboten es gab von ihnen keinen
einzigen versuch keinen einzigen versuch
die bereitschaft abzurufen es hat dazu
kein gespräch gegeben sie haben nach der
reise durch die bundesländer sich nicht
dafür entschieden jetzt alle an einen
tisch zu holen sie hätten jedoch an der
ehre packen können stattdessen nehmen
sie sicher sie haben gerade gesagt in
die pflicht und in die pflicht geben
heißt verordnung von oben als
durchregieren der ampel stadt
gemeinschaftswerk stadt partnerschaft
auf augenhöhe damit vergeben sie eine
chance
das ist ja es ist ihr formales recht
mehrheit ist mehrheit aber breite
mehrheiten über regierungen opposition
hinweg bringt ein mehrwert gerade in
diesen tagen wo es um akzeptanz geht und
am ende wird es vor ort um akzeptanz
fragen gehen und es wird kritische
diskussionen geben wir haben dem
energiewirtschaftsgesetz wo es um die
beschleunigung teile dieses aus der
pakets um die beschleunigung des
netzausbaus geht die man mir in der
letzten woche zugestimmt und ich habe
dort ausdrücklich gesagt dass ich glaube
ist ein mehrwert für akzeptanz dass in
diesem haus außerdem von linksaußen den
radikalen rechts die breite mitte
zustimmen wenn wir dann gemeinsam vor
ort hinstellen kann und sagen das haben
wir gemeinsam ist los nicht regierung
gegen opposition zur regierung mit
opposition das hätte ich ihnen für die
erneuerbaren angeboten diese
bereitschaft gab es auch beim wind sie
haben sich abgerufen eine verpasste
chance
und ja
auch bei den tieren dass generell die
opposition darauf hingewiesen und ich
möchte diesen wald schon etwas zurück
spielen da werden es hürden abgebaut die
abgebaut werden müssen sie greifen jetzt
auf das thema ausgleich windkraft und
naturschutz da haben übrigens die
umweltminister aller länder über viele
jahre darüber diskutiert und keine
lösung gefunden keinen vorschlag immer
die umweltministerkonferenz sie dafür
ordinär zuständigen ist gut das hat was
einen schritt macht und der
umweltministerkonferenz sind elf grüne
minister eine von der cdu und einige
andere also dass es auf eine
parteipolitische frage zu verkürzen das
ist wirklich eine kleinkarierte
parteipolitische sichtweise wir stellen
schon das gemeinschaftswerk und da will
ich ihnen sagen sie von eben potenziale
sie errichten eine klassengesellschaft
der erneuerbaren da ist wind und sonne
und focus hätten gesagt welche
potenziale bei der sonne noch mehr drin
gewesen hat und wirklich einen boom zu
erreichen aber im windschatten ist die
geothermie ist die biomasse und ist die
wasserkraft auf unseren druck hin auf
unseren druck mit unseren anträgen hier
im bundestag in der ersten lesung hätte
ich ihm gesagt die wasserkraft ist das
faule ei in ihrem masterplan haben sie
erkannt sie haben es erkannt ja ich bin
ist es ist bemerkenswert dass die grünen
lieber angetreten sind mit dem hinweis
bei den erneuerbaren geht es auch um
bürger energie und jeder beitrag zählt
ist immer jeder beitrag zählt wenn es
generell gilt jetzt auch für die kleine
wasserkraft gut dass sie auf unserer
brust nach dessen
und ich finde herr minister habe ist es
schon bemerkenswert schon bemerkenswert
dass an dem tag an dem sie die
kohlekraft die ihre partei über viele
jahre als schmutzig bekämpfte
wiederbeleben und wir können
nachvollziehen das ist gemacht wir
finden nur kohlekraft als co2 intensive
energieform ist nicht alternativlos und
wir machen hier in dieser wird
diskutieren heute abend dabei hier in
dieser debatte machen wir einen
konkreten vorschlag nämlich die biomasse
zu nutzen da belassen sie es bei dem
deckel der könnte es sofort mehr gemacht
werden und schlimmer noch werden sie die
kohlekraft hochfahren wird biomasse
weiter gedeckelt wird biomethan in kraft
wärme kopplungs anlagen gedrosselt am
selben tag die co2 intensive kohlen hoch
die biomasse gedeckelt das hat mit
grüner politik im sinne eines
ökologischen verständnisses nichts zu
tun
das führt uns dazu dass wir an diesem
gemeinschaftswerk festhalten und bei
allem ärger auch über das verfahren ist
teilweise unterirdisch gewesen ist bis
spät heute nacht die gesetzesvorlagen in
der sache beurteilen sind vier pakete im
oster gesetz eeg wurde noch rein
gedrückt auch dass kein angemessener
umgang mit der wichtigen frage der
energieeffizienz bei zwei davon stehen
wir dazu
netzausbau haben das schon gemacht bei
wind auf see stimmen dazu aus den
genannten gründen und weil sie dort
anders als bei diesem gesetz unsere
berechtigte kritik nicht aufgegriffen
haben können wir dieses paket insgesamt
nicht mittragen es ist ihm viel ja es
ist schon überraschend war er bei zwei
zensierter vorher mitmachen und sie
deswegen ja daran dass wir inhaltlich
diskutieren so wie ich es im ausschuss
noch mit prinzipien nachgegeben sind es
gemacht aber es ist bei allem was damit
vorangebracht hat das will ich nicht
bestreiten eben auch ein paket der
verpassten chancen das ist ihre
verantwortung in ihrem
andreas jung für die unionsfraktion war
schon immer ein wenig weiter was das
thema neuer baarer energien angeht als
ein großer teil seiner fraktion kann das
aus der opposition heraus natürlich sehr
viel deutlicher und klarer ausspielen
als es noch in der großen koalition war
und er hat gesagt englische meister hat
gerade draußen gesagt das war bei uns im
interview das werden wir ihn sicherlich
nachher nochmal zu spielen matthias
miersch ist am pult stellvertretender
vorsitzender der spd fraktion
und jetzt gehen wir zur tagesordnung
über frau präsidentin ich finde diese
gute stimmung kann bleiben denn jetzt
verabschieden wir das größte
gesetzespaket zur förderung der
erneuerbaren energien seit dem
erneuerbaren-energien-gesetz im jahre
2000 das ist ein kapo radfahrer
und wie bei andreas so dass nun
ausgerechnet wird die cdu/csu
anfängt mit symbolik dass der kanzler
nicht da ist das ist so bezeichnet weil
in der sache her frei haben sie ihm
nichts zu bieten sie haben kein
innerpolitischen einen
energiepolitischen kompass sie haben wir
haben in all den jahren und ich glaube
ich bin einer der besten zeugen
jeglichen ausbau jeglichen fortschritt
immer wieder verhindert die mussten
kämpfen kämpfen gegen solar deckel
gegenwind abstandsregeln sie standen auf
der bremse 16 jahre lang
und es ist ja noch viel schlimmer als
robert habeck ist er gesagt hat herr
merz gehen sie ruhig wenn sie es jetzt
nicht aushalten können aber ich muss
ihnen sagen sie
haben im märz vorgeschlagen hier ein gas
embargo gegenüber russland sie hätten
ein energiepolitisches desaster bereits
im märz angerichtet
und deswegen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das ist wirklich fortschritt
das ist fortschritt koalition und ich
möchte mich bei allen kolleginnen und
kollegen die an diesem gesetzeswerk
teilgenommen haben mitgewirkt haben ganz
ganz herzlich bedanken
das erste mal in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik deutschland sagt der
gesetzgeber dass der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien von überragendem
öffentlichen interesse ist das ist ein
wichtiges signal an alle
genehmigungsbehörden in diesem land
das erste mal kriegen wir einen
verbindlichen mechanismus zum ausbau
wind an land zwischen bund und
bundesländern es wird nicht mehr möglich
sein dass sich einzelne bundesländer
wegducken und an dieser großen
herausforderung nicht beteiligt sind
ihre kolleginnen und kollegen
und ich bin sehr stolz dass es uns auch
im parlamentarischen verfahren noch
gelungen ist beim thema photovoltaik
ordentlich nachzulegen und hier wirklich
die fesseln zu lösen wir werden jetzt
wie hemmnisse die wir gehabt haben
stichwort teil einspeisung beseitigen
wir werden neue flächen erschließen auch
das sind ganz ganz wichtige
entscheidungen die wir hier heute
treffen die wird kolleginnen und
kollegen
aber es wird weitergehen es gibt keinen
grund sich zurückzulehnen vor uns steht
eine herkulesaufgabe und genau beim
thema planung mann fehlen mein thema
genehmigungsrecht werden wir weiter
nachlegen müssen es kann nicht sein das
was gerade in niedersachsen passiert ist
dass ein verein zur denkmalpflege der in
karlsruhe ansässig ist den ausbau von
windkraft in lüneburg verhindert meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren das geht
nicht und
deswegen da bin ich mir sehr sehr da bin
ich mir sehr sicher wird diese
fortschritts koalition auch die nächsten
notwendigen schritte machen und
entscheiden und wir werden das auf leben
was die liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der cdu csu in den letzten jahren nicht
geschafft haben wo sie auf der bremse
waren weil sie schlichtweg
energiepolitisch einen blindflug haben
das ist die wahrheit und das müssen sie
ertragen ich danke für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
matthias miersch stellvertretender
vorsitzender der spd-fraktion und ihm
wird jetzt folgen aus den reihen der
fdp-fraktion die
[Musik]
bau und wohnungspolitischer sprecher
marc bernhard
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
sie von der ampel wollen heute
beschließen dass zukünftig zwei prozent
der fläche deutschlands
ausschließen ausschließlich für wind
industrieanlagen bereitgestellt werden
stand heute haben wir
31.000 und benötigen dafür 0,5 prozent
der landesfläche und jetzt vervierfachen
sie diese fläche so dass zukünftig bis
zu
120000 dieser anlagen auch in
unmittelbarer nähe von wohngebieten
gebaut werden können und es handelt sich
hierbei eben nicht um romantische
windrädchen sondern um monster anlagen
mit einer gesamthöhe von über
240 metern das ist ungefähr so wie wenn
man auf dem kölner dom ein propeller mit
160 metern durchmesser an bringen würde
und sollten die länder ist nicht
schaffen ihre vorgegebenen flächen
quoten zu erfüllen fallen die
mindestabstände zu wohnhäusern und damit
können solche giganten zukünftig auch
auf der wiese 500 meter vor jedem
wohnhaus stehen und es ist ihr gesetz
oder wo sein denn sonst die 90.000
weiteren wind industrieanlagen
hingestellt werden wenn man sich den
windatlas meiner heimat baden
württemberg anschaut kommt da eigentlich
nur das schwarzwald und die schwäbische
alb in frage
die pläne der ampel werden also
unweigerlich dazu führen dass große
teile des schwarzwalds abgeholzt werden
denn für jede windindustrie anlage
müssen 1,5 hektar wald gerodet werden
wenn sie also in zukunft von karlsruhe
200 kilometer durch die ferienregion zur
schweizer grenze fahren zehn kilometer
für kilometer nur noch windrad ein
windrad
während die grünen gegen die rodung von
läppischen 100 hektar im hambacher forst
protestiert haben fordern sie jetzt
bei der windkraft das abholzen von
zehntausenden hektar wald und schaffen
zudem die mindestabstände zu wohnhäusern
praktisch ab dabei ist ihm ganz
offensichtlich
völlig egal dass menschen die im umfeld
von wind industrieanlagen wohnen unter
infraschall und zermürbenden
lichtreflexen nein ganz zu schweigen von
den zahllosen tieren die in diesen
industrieanlagen tag für tag
geschreddert werden jedes jahr
250.000 fledermäuse
600.000 vögel wie storch rotmilane usa
sowie sechs milliarden bienen käfer und
andere insekten jeden tag und wofür
opfern sie das für eine reine ideologie
basierte energiewende die unsere
energiesicherheit massiv gefährdet und
dazu führt dass wir die höchsten
strompreise der welt haben
und dabei wäre es doch so einfach
wenn wir einfach das machen würden was
der rest der welt macht nämlich die drei
aktiven kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen
lassen wir kürzlich die drei kürzlich
abgeschalteten wieder in betrieb nehmen
unsere kohle kraftwerke weiter laufen
lassen und in moderne
kraftwerkstechnologien und synthetische
kraftstoffe investieren erst vorgestern
hat das eu-parlament
bestätigt dass es sich bei der
kernenergie um eine grüne und
nachhaltige technologie handelt und
deshalb hat belgien die laufzeiten
seiner kernkraftwerke um zehn jahre
verlängert frankreich plant 14 neue
großbritannien 6 und in finnland haben
die grünen den bau von kernkraftwerken
in ihr parteiprogramm aufgenommen
deutschland ist also mal wieder der
geisterfahrer in europa meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren anstatt umwelt
arbeitsplätze und energiesicherheit zu
zerstören müssen wir jetzt endlich diese
geisterfahrt stoppen herzlichen dank
marc bernhard für die fpd fraktion ich
bin relativ sicher dass der schwarzwald
und dem ausbau erneuerbarer energien er
nicht bleiben wird michael kruse ist der
nächste redner kommt aus der fdp
fraktion und ist energiepolitischer
sprecher dort
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
lieben kolleginnen und kollegen wir
beschließen heute das beste was
deutschland je hatte und
ich kann vor allem die fachliche kritik
die hier aus reihen der union gekommen
ist habe ich mir sehr genau angehört ich
kann sie aber nicht teilen weil mit
diesem gesetzespaket und insbesondere
der kombination aus eeg und em wgw sie
auch angesprochen haben erstmalig eine
vernünftige verknüpfung in diesem land
gelungen ist zwischen dem was wir an
produktionskapazitäten ausbauen und dem
was wir an transportkapazitäten ausbauen
es gab noch nie diesen lückenschluss
zwischen eeg und ewg produktion und netz
die ampel regierung bringt genau das
auch den weg und schon deswegen hätten
diese gesetze heute von ihnen eine
zustimmung für die
etablieren mit diesem heutigen beschluss
ein marktwirtschaftliches regime eeg
ließ das bisher noch nicht kannte wir
stärken die marktwirtschaftlichen
instrumenten und beschleunigen damit den
ausbau und auch diejenigen hier im haus
die richtig große fans von vom abbau von
subventionen sind die könnten hier heute
eigentlich zustimmen weil wir erstmalig
vereinbart haben dass mit dem tag wo wir
aus der kohleverstromung aussteigen auch
dies das voerder ende für die
erneuerbaren erreichte ist das heißt es
ist ein anreiz für diejenigen die gerne
die erneuerbaren ausbauen möchten und es
ist auch ein anreiz für all diejenigen
die sagen naja die subventionierung in
dem bereich die muss ja nicht mehr so
stark ausfallen also wir laden sie
herzlich ein insbesondere liebe union
diesen gesetzen heute zuzustimmen sie
haben gute gründe dafür
und auch wenn man auf die preise schauen
das ja eine der zentralen argumente in
dieser debatte wenn man auf die preise
schaut dann muss man eben sagen die
erneuerbaren lohnen sich mittlerweile
ökologisch waren sie schon immer
vorteilhaft aber neuerdings sind sie
eben auch ökonomisch vorteilhaft und das
ist spätestens der moment wo eigentlich
ab diesem teil im haus eine neubewertung
stattfinden sollte die erneuerbaren sie
lohnen sich ökologisch sie lohnen sich
mittlerweile wirtschaftlich und
wichtigstes argument in diesem jahr sie
stärken unsere
unabhängigkeit von bestimmten ländern
die nicht in unserem interesse handelt
und deswegen sagen wir ihnen wir wollen
die resilienz stärken er sich von der
fdp wollen die resultieren in
deutschland gar nicht stärken wir wollen
die resilienz dieses landes stärken und
deswegen sagen wir erneuerbare energien
sind frei heizenergie in meine damen und
herren
und die basis für diese tolle preisliche
entwicklung liegt legen legen wir mit
der abschaffung der eeg-umlage aber
damit wird es nicht auf wenn wir wind
flächen versteigern werden die einnahmen
aus diesen versteigerungen zukünftig in
die absenkung der offshore wind umlage
fließen und damit sorgen wir dafür dass
der erneuerbaren ausbau auch nicht den
menschen in diesem land zu sehr auf dem
portemonnaie liegt sondern wir sorgen
dafür dass die einnahmen aus diesem
bereich auch in dem bereich ausbau
verbleiben und damit die strompreise
dauerhaft gesenkt werden können meine
lieben kolleginnen und kollegen
wir versehen wird
wir haben erstmalig eine speicher
strategie festgelegt dunkel flaute habe
ich aus dieser region des hauses sehr
oft gehört ja was wie lösen wir denn das
thema indem wir die erneuerbaren auch
verfügbar machen in den zeiten wo der
wind nicht weht und die sonne nicht
scheint deswegen setzen wir auf eine
speicher strategie und spoiler ich kann
ihnen verraten
die arbeit an diesen gesetzen sie wird
sogar noch weiter gehen weil wir nicht
stoppen werden bis wir das optimale
markt design in diesem bereich erreicht
haben damit alle die einen speicher zur
verfügung haben in zukunft auch
preissignale bekommen und wir damit die
erneuerbaren in teil eines
marktwirtschaftlichen
energiesystems überführen herzlichen
dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
michael kruse der energiepolitische
sprecher der fdp fraktion spricht von
dem erneuerbaren als freiheits energien
und mal sehen wie ralph lenkert das
einordnet umweltpolitischer sprecher der
linksfraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen energie ist
daseinsvorsorge und das energie
versorgungssicherheit auch beim umstieg
auf 100 prozent erneuerbar unabdingbar
ist das predigt in meiner fraktion seit
jahren
ein erneuerbare und bezahlbares system
ist machbar aber ihre vorschläge sind
für mich als techniker unzureichend das
wind und solarenergie schneller
ausgebaut werden müssen und dass dafür
auch flächen benötigt werden das
unterstützt die linke viel mehr pv strom
ist richtig aber für die extreme
stromerzeugung mittags bei sonnenschein
und 40 solarstrom nacht haben sie keine
lösung zur nutzung der extrem schwanken
solar erzeugung braucht es ein
energiespeicher programm ein system mit
batterien und pumpspeichern zum
kurzfristigen ausgleich der realen
stromerzeugung
mit wärme speichern zur
energiespeicherung für mehrere tage und
mit wasserstoff elektrolyse und rückt
vor strom und zur saisonalen speicherung
ein förderprogramm für die direkte
nutzung von tvn lüftungs und
klimaanlagen in schulen krankenhäusern
und öffentlichen gebäuden ideal für die
mittagszeit an heißen sommertagen das
will die linke
der windkraftausbau an land wie auch sie
und ich kann das märchen nicht mehr
hören dass der naturschutz das problem
ist die meisten einwände erfolgen wegen
mangelnder regionale akzeptanz bei den
menschen wer mit dem windrad lebt soll
auch etwas davon haben das fordert die
linke
die realität in ostdeutschland ist
leider anders die investoren kommt nicht
aus der region wegen notwendigen
netzausbau stiegen die strompreise vor
ort
projektbeteiligung sind oft nicht
vorgesehen gewesen oder wegen fehlender
mittel den menschen und kommunen
unmöglich deshalb folgen sie unseren
vorschlägen es braucht einheitliche
netzentgelte für alle stromkunden und
kunden in austin west in der stadt auf
dem land
für jede erzeugte kilowattstunde
windstrom erhalten die anliegerkommunen
0,5 cent ausgezahlt das ergebe circa
20.000 euro pro windkraft und ja anlage
und jahr für schulen für kindergärten
für feuerwehr in den gemeinden
installieren sie haben es gerade an
wohngebäuden damit sichergestellt ist
dass lärm grenzwerte auch ohne abstand
regeln eingehalten werden
die schlechte personelle ausstattung der
genehmigungsbehörden und auch der
gerichte bei klagen verlängert oder
verderb planung sorgen sie endlich für
genügend fachpersonal
100.000 arbeitsplätze setzte ging in der
solarindustrie zehntausende in der
produktion von windkraftanlagen in
deutschland verloren wegen der
verfehlten politik von union und den
unions-geführten regierungen
wir fordern regionale produktion zu
fördern
tarifliche arbeitsplätze zu schaffen und
damit akzeptanz voranzubringen eben auch
mit der produktion von windkraftanlagen
in deutschland und auch den standort in
rostock zu erhalten
kolleginnen und kollegen
stadt verstärkt naturschutzgebiete für
die windkraftnutzung fordere ich dass
die bundeswehr und die alliierten
truppen ihre truppenübungsplätze für
windkraftanlagen öffnen dann kann die
gruppe auch realitätsnahen
dass die deutsche flugsicherung neue
funkfeuer nutzt und die sperrzone
verkleinert werden es notwendig und ein
letzter punkt die linke fordert zum
system der festvergütung von windenergie
zurückzukehren das würde
planungssicherheit für anlagen
betreiberinnen und betreiber und
preissicherheit für kundinnen und kunden
bedeuten und schließt die spekulation
mit windkraft zu lasten von
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher aus
vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin für die fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen dr julie
& julia fehlenden ist stellvertretende
vorsitzende der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen
die lage ist ernst putin überzieht die
ukraine mit einem andauernden
angriffskrieg in der folge sind die
energiemärkte aus den fugen geraten
weltweit die fossilien preise spielen
verrückt die energieversorgung muss neu
abgesichert werden gas einsparungen hat
höchste priorität
aber das ist nicht alles die lage ist
ebenso ernst wenn wir auf die klima
erhitzung schauen inzwischen erleben wie
er nahezu tagtäglich wie rasant sich die
klimakrise verschärft extreme
trockenheit in italien waldbrände in
griechenland italien der türkei und auch
hier bei uns in brandenburg
gletscher abbrüche in der arktis oder
zuletzt in den alpen in indien eine
extreme hitzewelle und heftige
überschwemmungen
das sind nur einige wenige beispiele für
bedrohliche wetter extreme die
menschenleben gefährden unsere
lebensgrundlagen zerstören und
volkswirtschaftliche werte vernichten
die aufgrund der klimaerwärmung häufiger
und heftiger werden noch haben wir es in
der hand diese entwicklung abzubremsen
klima wird das buch und massives arten
aussterben verhindern dass das hängt
maßgeblich von den entscheidungen in
diesem parlament ab
wir sind als andere koalition angetreten
endlich den notwendigen fortschritt beim
klimaschutz zu schaffen und heute
liefern wir nur ein halbes jahr nachdem
diese koalition angetreten ist
beschließen wir ein großes energiepaket
das den ausbau von wind- und
solarenergie in bisher nie dagewesenen
großen schritten voran bringen wird
jahrelang jahre lang wurden die freiheit
energien von der union gedeckelt
gebremst bürokratisiert diese fatalen
fehler der vorgängerregierung reparieren
wir nun der ausbau
der ausbau der erneuerbaren energien ist
neben der energieeinsparung der
entscheidende schritt für den
klimaschutz denn nur mit wind und
solarenergie und den anderen
erneuerbaren energien können wir
dauerhaft unseren energiebedarf co2
decken deshalb machen wir jetzt den weg
frei für milliarden investitionen die
sie verhindert haben in den letzten
jahren
wir sorgen für ausreichend flächen für
windräder mit nur zwei prozent der
fläche in deutschland können wir einen
großteil unserer energieversorgung
sicherstellen alle bundesländer müssen
ihren beitrag leisten das schafft
verbindlichkeit und planungssicherheit
und wir sorgen dafür dass die dächer
endlich voll gemacht werden mit
solarenergie außerdem schaffen wir auch
neue möglichkeiten für mehr photovoltaik
über parkplätzen bis hin zur
doppelnutzung von landwirtschaftlich
genutzten flächen gesetze beschließen
das ist das eine jetzt sind kommunen und
bundesländer dran jetzt geht es in die
umsetzung vor ort
das erfolgsrezept des starts der
energiewende von über 20 jahren waren
die investitionen der vielen die bürger
energiewende
energiegenossenschaften und kommunen
denen machen wir es mit dieser
gesetzesnovelle endlich wieder leichter
mitzumachen so schaffen wir die
voraussetzungen die wichtigen
voraussetzung um endlich schnell und
dauerhaft von kohle öl und gas
loszukommen
liebe kolleginnen die verhandlungen die
bahn intensiv das vorliegende
energiepaket hat allen seiten
zugeständnisse abverlangt denn natürlich
sind drei partner nicht immer einer
meinung aber wir haben bewiesen dass wir
diesen willen und die kraft haben dinge
voranzubringen und das werden wir auch
weiterhin tun die energiewende ist noch
lange nicht fertig vor allem bei der
energieeffizienz und beim energiesparen
müssen und werden weitere schritte
folgen denn die abhängigkeit von
fossilen energien die lösen wir nicht
allein mit den erneuerbaren es braucht
auch eine ambitionierte energieeffizienz
politik hier weniger kilowattstunden
deutschland verbraucht unserer schaffen
wir nicht vollversorgung mit
erneuerbaren so rascher wenn die
unabhängig von teuren importen die
sparsam mit technik die effizienten
produktionsmethoden all das muss nicht
erfunden werden es gibt es alles bereits
meine damen und herren es ist ein großer
schritt für die erneuerbaren was wir
hier heute beschließen und ich freue
mich auf viele weitere gute gesetze für
mehr klimaschutz und energie
souveränität vielen dank
julia fällt hinten für die fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen wo sie eine der
stellvertretenden fraktionsvorsitzenden
ist mag helfrich mit der nächste redner
sein und der kommt aus der
unionsfraktion
nächster redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
mag helfrich
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen mit dem im frühjahr
vorgestellten paket hat die ampel
regierung der republik viele bunte eier
ins osternest gelegt diese sollten die
energiepolitische ausrichtung unseres
landes neu ordnen und den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien vorantreiben viele
dieser eier haben sich leider als faule
eier herausgestellt
auf die massive kritik von verbänden und
opposition hat die ampel reagiert und
einige dieser feier ausgetauscht dies
betrifft insbesondere die geplante
klimaneutralität in der stromversorgung
bis 20 35 eine solche festlegung hätte
massive auswirkungen auf die
versorgungssicherheit in deutschland mit
sich gebracht auch bei der kleinen
wasserkraft ist die ampel auf unsere
position eingeschränkt diese soll
zukünftig wie alle erneuerbaren energien
im überragenden öffentlichen interesse
sein und wie bisher gefördert werden
leider fehlt uns jedoch die einbeziehung
der vor ort stromnetze unter 110 kv in
das überragende öffentliche interesse so
wird ist weiterhin realität bleiben dass
der so wichtige grüne strom zwar
produziert aber das netz beziehungsweise
die verteilung des stroms
hinterherhinken
mehr mut zur veränderung hätten wir uns
auch bei den kleinen solaranlagen auf
dächern gewünscht jedoch wird hier
leider auch zukünftig zwischen der voll
und teil 1 speisung bei der
einspeisevergütung unterschieden
eigenverbrauch ist aber ganz klar der
treiber der privaten dachflächen tv
die neue möglichkeit teil und voll
einspeiseanlagen nebeneinander zu
instanz yanez bürokratischer irrsinn und
treibt zudem die kosten für die bürger
in die höhe
auch hat sich die ampel leider nicht zu
einer vereinfachung der besteuerung von
einspeisevergütung für kleine
dachanlagen bis 30 kw peak durchgerungen
wir hatten hier gefordert kleine
dachanlagen von der steuer und abgaben
pflicht zu befreien anstelle einer
einnahme überschuss rechnung hätte doch
zumindest eine pauschale besteuerung
drin sein müssen erhältlich gestatten
sie eine frage aus der fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen sehr gern sie haben das
wort
ja herzlichen dank für arbeit
tatsächlich gerade wirklich mit
hochdruck und an sehr vielen gesetzen
gleichzeitig deswegen wollte ich aber
nur einmal damit das nicht falsch
stehenbleibt wir haben das überragende
öffentliche interesse für verteilnetze
beschlossen aber schon in dem paket mit
ewg weg und commerce bedarfsplan gesetzt
und kommen jetzt auch eine frage noch
anzuschließen sie hatten ja gerade noch
angesprochen pv und 30 kw das steuer im
steuerrecht geändert werden soll auch
das haben wir im änderungsantrag schon
festgehalten dass wir das tun werden wir
können nicht alle gesetze gleichzeitig
ändern oder das bekam man ist nicht mehr
gut machen und kriegt es glaube ich wir
haben sie mit skis und anderen jetzt
schon fest kam irgendwie haben sie mit
schließungs antrag dokumentiert und aber
hatten sie wirklich dass wir alle
gesetze gleichzeitig ändern oder können
sie auch damit umgehen dass wir mit
voller kraft und ich glaube ich zehn elf
gesetzt sie auf einen einen hof gemacht
dass das schon ein großer schritt ist
und ja wir werden das andere auch ändern
bleiben sie bitte zur antwort stehen
kollegin gute kollegin dr nestlé sie
haben sich in ihrem eigenen statement
noch einmal korrigiert also in der tat
sie haben das thema steuervereinfachung
im entschließungsantrag weil sie sich
nicht geeinigt haben bei dem thema sie
haben es auf die zukunft verschoben aber
ich würde dieses statement jetzt als
zusage als verbindliche zusage an
diejenigen die pv dachflächen
anlagen sich installieren verstehen dass
das sehr sehr bald kommen wird also in
der zweiten jahreshälfte das ist eine
gute nachricht des heutigen tages und
wenn es um die das öffentlich
überragende öffentliche interesse bei
den verteilnetzen geht dann stimmt das
nur für 110 kv eben für die 110 kv ebene
für alles was darunter liegt leider
nicht
[Applaus]
auf jeden fall werden wir wenn wir diese
motive der menschen nicht in den
mittelpunkt stellen die dächer in diesem
land nicht voll bekommen
auch beim mieter strom und er lässt die
ampel praxistaugliche änderungen die
möglichkeit von millionen mietern von
der erneuerbaren stromproduktion zu
profitieren wird leider nur marginal
verbessert wir hingegen fordern die
erweiterung der mieter strom förderung
auch auf nebengebäude und die erhöhung
des mieter strom zuschlages ein weiterer
großer kritikpunkt sind die im vergleich
zur anzahl der entwickelten projekte
sehr hohen ausbau raten für windenergie
an land und solarenergie damit sie mich
nicht falsch verstehen natürlich
befürworten wir den zügigen ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien wer aber
ausschreibung mangels ausreichender
anzeige boote ins leere laufen lässt
derzeit nachher immer den höchstpreis
und damit kolleginnen und kollegen von
der ampel führen sie ihre politik der
übertriebenen kostenbelastung für
wirtschaft und bürger fort im gegensatz
zu den überaus ambitionierten zielen bei
der wind- und solarenergie lässt die
ampel die potenziale der bioenergie
links liegen sie verhindern dass mehr
biomethan ins gasnetz kommt zudem ist
der einsatz von biomethan nur noch in
hoch flexiblen kraftwerken vorgesehen
die höchstens an zehn prozent der
stunden eines jahres strom erzeugen
dürfen selbst in der krise wo es darum
geht die erdgas verstromung zu
minimieren verhindern sie die eine
erhöhung der stromproduktion und
vorhandenen biogasanlagen vielmehr
brauchen wir ein system steuerbare
erneuerbare und speicher
einen kleinen lichtblick im oster paket
bietet hingegen dass wind auf sie
gesetzt hier haben die ampel fraktionen
nachgebessert und erleichtern durch
kleinere ausschreibungs lose mehr
unternehmen den zugang zu offshore
windprojekten gleiches gilt für die
neuen ausschreibungskriterien
fachkräftesicherung sowie co2 fußabdruck
leider hat die ampel das von uns
geforderte kriterium der guten
vereinbarkeit mit belangen der fischerei
nicht aufgenommen und sprite führte auch
der angestrebte ausbau der windparks zu
einem grossen verlust von fanggebieten
und gefährdet die existenz vieler
fischereibetriebe
immerhin hat die ampel die fischerei bei
der kompensation aus den aufschwung
gebotene 5 prozent berücksichtigt auch
der schon lange von der union geforderte
industrie strompreis hat es in das
gesetz geschafft dieser soll dafür
sorgen dass der energieintensiven
industrie ausreichend erneuerbarer strom
zu international wettbewerbsfähigen
preisen zur verfügung steht insgesamt
stimmen wir ihrem wind auf sie gesetzt
zu
erlauben sie mir noch einen letzten satz
zum gebäude energie gesetz das an das
eeg angehängt wurde wer in zeiten von
höchst inflation steigende baupreise und
dozierenden zinsen noch höhere
baustandards 1 für ohne vorher eine
entsprechende förderung zu etablieren
lässt den traum vom eigenheim für viele
bürgerinnen und bürger endgültig platzen
und allein aus diesem grund können wir
dem aus wenig licht und viel schatten
bestehenden e g 20 23 nicht zustimmen
mag helfrich aus der unionsfraktion hat
in seinem debattenbeitrag
wiederholt die abkürzung pv verwendet
jetzt weiß ich natürlich dass sie alle
genau wissen was damit gemeint ist
nämlich die photovoltaik also die
umwandlung von lichtenergie meistens
sonne mittels solarzellen in elektrische
energie jetzt habe ich sie trotzdem noch
mal erklärt nina scheer umwelt und
sprecherin für klimaschutz und energie
der spd fraktion verlangen wenn ihre
wortmeldung sie hat es völlig korrekt
wiedergegeben sie haben übersehen dass
die verteilnetzebene bereits jetzt als
überragende öffentliche interesse
gestellt wurde mit der letzten novelle
in der letzten sitzungswoche enwg bzw
energiewirtschaftsgesetz und diese
andere frage die hat sie noch mal noch
mal betont dass dies schon in dem
entschließungsantrag drin steht nämlich
die steuerliche handhabung von kleiner
blick auf menschen ist ob sie sich auch
nicht korrigieren müssen es ist wirklich
erbärmlich mit welchen methoden sie
versuchen eine sachlichkeit ihrer
argumentation zu suggerieren die einfach
nicht gegeben ist hat er
aktuell gerade
die aktuelle lage zeigt dass wir so
schnell wie möglich auf erneuerbare
energien umsteigen müssen das ist nicht
erst mit dem heutigen oster paket klar
das wissen wir seit einiger zeit und in
der tat hätte in den vergangenen
jahrzehnten schon viel mehr passieren
müssen wir hatten unter rot grün im jahr
2000 mathias merta des schon erwähnten
die weichen dafür gestellt leider wurde
es in den regierungsjahren dazwischen
unter torpedierung insbesondere aus
ihren reihen auch teilweise
verschlechtert was wir an
rahmenbedingungen hatten und damit
räumen wir jetzt wird setzt sich aus
der wissenschaft von der massiven
importabhängigkeit von fossilen
ressourcen wegzukommen das geht nur mit
erneuerbaren energien wir sehen auch
dass wir in eine preisfalle hineintappen
wenn wir nicht so schnell wie möglich
auf erneuerbare energien umsteigen und
deswegen ist dies ein so herausragend
wichtiges gesetzeswerk weil wir die
weichen für diese ermöglichung stellen
dass wir uns unabhängig machen dass wir
uns unabhängig von preisdiktaten machen
und damit auch ein wirksames mittel
gegen diese kriegerische
instrumentalisierung der energiepolitik
setzen die jetzt von seiten des
präsidenten putin aus russland heraus
lanciert wird und auch in richtung die
der energieversorgung mit gas gespielt
wird das ist also hier auch eine antwort
und eine sehr wichtige antwort in dem
außenpolitischen kontext den wir hier
gerade zu bewältigen haben
und wir müssen ich habe es erwähnt
erneuerbaren energien noch die
günstigsten formen auch ganz klar die
linie ziehen ein rückwärtsgewandtes noch
mal wieder beleben von atomenergie kann
nicht helfen selbst eine verlängerung
ist rückwärtsgewandt weil wir wissen
dass ist am teuersten ist auf
atomenergie zu setzen wir sehen an den
franzosen dass sie große probleme haben
gerade in den sommermonaten mit dürren
und mit niedrig flusswasser regeln dass
eben diese atomkraftwerke nicht mehr
gekühlt werden deswegen in angesicht
einer steigenden
klimakatastrophe klimawandel der klang
des des steigen klimawandels wäre es
wirklich ein himmelfahrtskommando ist
wenn wir uns weiterhin abhängig machen
und jede verlängerung ist natürlich
abhängig
[Applaus]
wenn wir das verlegen warum sollen wir
in dieser richtung noch mehr geld
ausgeben als wir durch den zickzackkurs
oder hirn schon ausgeben muss in ihr sie
zu verantworten
diese jetzt zu stellen
die energie werden das heißt erneuerbar
um die atomenergie
wir haben die richtigen wegmarken
gesetzt mit dem paket das wir 80 prozent
erneuerbaren energien bis 2030 haben
wollen und zwar bezugsgröße 750
terawattstunden das ist deutlich mehr
ein drittel mehr als heute gebraucht
wird das bedeutet wir hätten dann in 20
30 und werfen es haben mit den maßgaben
wir werden dann so viel erneuerbare
haben wie wenn wir heute mit dem
heutigen strombedarf schlafender prozent
wären diese dimension über diese reden
das ist eine vervierfachung des ausbaus
wir machen ein haben jetzt ein wind auf
see gesetz auf inder in der pipeline bis
zur verabschiedung wir haben ein bild an
land gesetzt sie haben das
erneuerbare-energien-gesetz haben
gebäude energie gesagt ich wollte noch
viele weitere sachen sagen das machen
meine kollegen ich danke für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
er verabschiedete vor allem dass diese
partie
nina scheer für die spd-fraktion und wir
alle wissen sie sie tochter von hermann
scheer träger des alternativen
nobelpreises eine von denen die schon
vor 15 20 jahren dafür geworben haben
und mit nachdruck darauf hingewiesen
haben wie dringlich unnötig ist auf
erneuerbare energien zu setzen weil
genau eine situation eintreten werde wie
wir sie heute haben
andreas black für die einstigen das
roster paket der bundesregierung ist
einer der grössten politischen anschläge
auf den artenschutz seit gründung des
bundesumweltministeriums und das nicht
trotz sondern wegen der grünen
bundesminister es ist doch entlarvend
dass kein einziger redner den atemschutz
hier mal länger thematisiert hat uns in
einem einzigen satz früher ging es noch
darum den artenschutz zu stärken jetzt
geht es nur noch darum den artenschutz
für die energiewende zu schwächen und
die abhängigkeit vom russischen öl und
gas durch die abhängigkeit von wind und
sonne zu ersetzen darauf kann man nur
als grüner kommen aber es ist
erstaunlich offensichtlich kann man auch
ohne die kernenergie verstrahlt sein die
art und weise wie die regierung das
gesetzgebungsverfahren durchgeführt hat
stellt eine grobe missachtung der rechte
der opposition dar bei der sondersitzung
des umweltausschusses wurden
änderungsanträge erst kurz vor oder
lange nach beginn an die ausschuss
mitglieder verschickt kein
ausschussmitglied die
oppositionsfraktionen hatte überhaupt
die chance diese änderungsanträge die
bis zu 3 128 seiten umfassten zu lesen
geschweige denn zu verstehen trotzdem
wurde darüber abgestimmt dass werte
kolleginnen und kollegen ist eine farce
und ein armutszeugnis für den
parlamentarismus
doch atemschutz fachliche gründe
sprechen gegen das oster paket egal
welchen der gesetzentwürfe man sich
anschaut bei jedem wird deutlich dass
die bundesregierung den klimaschutz
höhere priorität einräumt als den
artenschutz so wird ausschließlich der
bau von sogenannten erneuerbaren energie
als öffentliches interesse und als fall
für die öffentliche sicherheit
eingestuft nicht jedoch der erhalt der
biologischen vielfalt
abstände von coly von koalitions
gefährdeten brutvogelarten zu
windkraftanlagen werden drastisch
reduziert das ist gar nicht artenschutz
fachlich hergeleitet sondern das
politische willkür zu lasten unserer
natur das ornithologische fachwissen der
staatlichen vogelschutzwarte wird
ignoriert der fledermausschutz hat im
gesetzentwurf keine bedeutung und
darüber hinaus führt die bundesregierung
nur 15 arten in der liste
kollisionsgefahr dieter brutvogelarten
auf das verstößt eindeutig gegen das
europäische recht das sind der
vogelschutzrichtlinie den schutz aller
geschützten vogelarten vorsieht und
damit setzen wir uns einem
vertragsverletzungsverfahren aus die
ausweisung von zwei prozent der fläche
deutschlands
für den bau von wind industrie anlagen
wird nicht nur freiflächen sondern auch
zunehmend wälder und schutzgebiete unter
druck setzen deswegen gilt auch hier
lieber einen grünen wald als einen
grünen im wald summa summarum die
bundesregierung hat ihren worten keine
taten folgen lassen sie hat viel
angekündigt und ist an ihren eigenen
ansprüchen gescheitert
mit ihrem oster paket legt die
bundesregierung uns also für faule eier
ins nest auf dieses unerwünschte und
verspätete geschenk können wir
verzichten und deshalb werden wir die
gesetzentwürfe ablehnen vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin für die fdp-fraktion
carina konrad und arena conradi seiner
der stellvertretenden
fraktionsvorsitzenden in der fdp
fraktion
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen gerade
weil doch alle bürgerinnen und bürger
gerade in unserem land spüren wie
abhängig wir geworden sind von putins
energie nadel gerade weil wir doch
wissen wie abhängig wir sind davon dass
unsere wirtschaft erfolgreich ist dass
unser boot stand geparkt war dass
tausende zehntausende arbeitsplätze in
unserem land auch weiterhin bestehen
bleiben gerade deshalb ist dieses
vorliegende gesetzespaket ein weiterer
großer erfolg dieser koalition
denn liebe union us-markt ihnen wissen
weil es auch einmal zeigen was alles
geht in diesem land um wie schnell es
auch gehen kann und jetzt nicht mehr
zeigt was man alles verhindern kann
unter der erde ab lag ich kann sie
beruhigen ich kann ihre tränen trocknen
der artenschutz kommt nicht unter die
räder der population schutz bleibt
gewahrt aber in atemschutz als
instrument zu nehmen für diejenigen die
deutschland schwächen wollen das wird in
der zukunft nicht mehr passieren und das
brauchen wir geändert
es darf keine verhinderung instrumente
mehr geben sondern es muss ermöglichung
instrumente geben in diesem land und
dazu gehört auch dass die energiewende
dass wir akzeptanz haben dafür dass
energien auch ausgebaut werden in
unserem land und da gehört alles dazu
gehört auch dazu dass man die
landwirtschaft mit nimmt das war uns
freien demokraten ein großes anliegen
auch bei der umsetzung dieses gesetzes
paketes das ist keine weiteren
bürokratischen belastungen gibt sondern
dass man den der landwirtschaft
ermöglicht auch davon partizipieren
gerade mit der erweiterung der flächen
kulisse für die atv ist uns das gelungen
und ein weiterer meilenstein gelegt
wurden dafür dass man auch nach vorne
schaut und aus der krise eine chance
sucht auf die kleine wasserkraft hat
eine chance entgegen dem was ihr schon
gesagt wurde vielleicht wird es auch
helfen wenn man einfach mal die vorlagen
die einem sagen vorgelegt werden es war
knapp ich gebe es zu es war eine große
aufgabe auch für sie aber man sollte das
auch mal lesen was da drin steht am ende
des tages eine kleine wasserkraft hat
eine zukunft in diesem land und hat es
sehr wichtig denn wir werden mit diesem
gesetzespaket wahrscheinlich nicht
stehen bleiben denn klar ist doch auch
wir brauchen jede kilowattstunde strom
und da darf es keine denken geben da
muss man auch ohne schaum vor dem mund
innerhalb unserer reihe miteinander
diskutieren wo es noch kilowattstunden
gibt die behoben werden können für die
zukunft und meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren es gibt ein thema was aus
diesem gesetzespaket heraus für uns auch
als auch david direkt noch vor der brust
und matthias miersch hat es schon gesagt
für uns drei demokraten ist das thema
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz lich das
zentrale thema dieser koalition und wir
werden dieses thema weiter forcieren und
haben hiermit einen auftrag eine
blaupause dafür geschaffen was alles
möglich sein muss über die erneuerbaren
energien herren hinaus auch zu
beschleunigen unserem land wir sehen
noch jeden tag die desolaten zustände
von brücken von straßen von schienen und
das ist eine blaupause auch hier neu zu
denken und das werden wir im nächsten
schritt tun vielen dank
carina konrad war das eine der
stellvertretenden vorsitzenden in der
fdp-fraktion der bundestag diskutiert
nach wie vor über den ausbau
erneuerbarer energien
da wird es gleich vier namentliche
abstimmung geben zu den gesetzentwürfen
die dazu vorliegen dazu später mehr
erstmal kathrin olic aus der fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen frau präsidentin
sehr geehrte damen und herren heute
ändert sich wirklich etwas in der
energiepolitik der minister hat es eben
schon ausgeführt mit dem ziel 80 prozent
erneuerbare energien im strombereich bis
20 30 zu erreichen beschleunigen wir
heute nicht nur den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien und reduzieren
unsere abhängigkeit von fossilen
importen sondern schützen vor allem
unser klima wir schaffen hier und jetzt
die voraussetzungen dafür dass
ausreichend windräder und solaranlagen
in zukunft für bezahlbare strompreise
sorgen werden wir machen die
energiewende zum mitmach projekt für
alle
mit dem heute vorliegenden entwurf
können wir das potenzial unserer dächer
als kraftwerke nutzen und unterstützen
die menschen bei der energiewende vor
ort wir machen stromversorgung vom
eigenen dach einfacher und sorgen dafür
dass diese nun auch unkompliziert mit
einer anlage die den strom direkt ins
netz einspeist kombiniert werden kann
gerade bürger energie projekte haben die
energiewende zu dem gemacht was sie
heute ist deshalb stärken wir solche
projekte endlich wieder und unterstützen
so eine dezentrale energieversorgung mit
vielfältigen akteuren
auch die industrie steht längst in den
startlöchern um wirklich teil der
energiewende zu werden wir stärken durch
das winter auf see gesetzt die
möglichkeit der industrie für den
direkten bezug von grünem strom und
schaffen durch eine
verordnungsermächtigung den rahmen für
einen industrie strompreis auf basis von
erneuerbaren energien
die kollegin verwenden hat es eben schon
angesprochen
viel zu lange wurde vor allem auch die
windenergie an land ausgebremst viel zu
wenig flächen wurden zur verfügung
gestellt darum regeln wir jetzt mit dem
winterland gesetz das künftig
ausreichend flächen bereitgestellt
werden und schaffen klarheit bei den
datenschutzrechtlichen regelungen lassen
sie uns die energiewende gemeinsam zu
einer erfolgsgeschichte machen und einem
exportschlager made in germany
nächster redner für die spd-fraktion
timon gremmels
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren lieber
ehemalige koalitionspartner cdu csu wie
war's denn mit ihnen mit ihnen haben wir
aus dem hause altmaier meistens
schlechte vorlagen bekommen und wir
konnten doch das schlimmste verhindern
und dafür haben wir dafür haben wir
dreieinhalb jahre gebraucht bis das
große de große reform kurz vor ende der
legislaturperiode in kraft tritt jetzt
ist es genau anders sie kriegt gute
vorlagen die hier im parlament verfahren
locker machen und sie haben nur ein
dreiviertel jahr gebraucht das ist der
unterschied zu ihrer
regierungsverantwortung und
kragen im bereich der photovoltaik
ausbau der solarenergie haben wir hier
einen riesengroßen schritt nach vorne
gemacht hier werden die voraussetzungen
dafür schaffen dass wir perspektivisch
pro jahr 22 gigawatt
photovoltaik hin zu bauen können das
lässt sich sehen das ist ambitioniert
und das erreichen wir durch
schutzmaßnahmen erstens bürokratie
runter zweitens vergütung auf drittens
dächer voll viertens freifläche
erweitert und fünftens bürgerbeteiligung
verbessert so geht soziale mit raschen
energiepolitik sowie die energiepolitik
dieser appell polizei wir werden
huszti runter wir werden dafür sorgen
dass der netzanschluss deutlich
vereinfacht wird dass das online geht
und dass die rahmenbedingen und
bundesweit einheitlich sind
installationsbetriebe schnell anlage ans
netz gehen können und das fertige
anlagen die da sind in der regel nicht
noch ein halbes jahr leer stehendes der
nets meisterschaft vorbei zu kommen auch
das verbessern wir auch das geht
deutlich schneller vergütung raus wir
werden die vergütung für thailand reise
deutlich verbessern dass ich mal eben
sich nicht mehr entscheiden muss ob man
teile oder voll einspeist und dafür
werden wir sorgen dass die dächer
volllaufen dass die dächer mit
photovoltaik anlagen gesteckt werden wir
keine freien fläche mehr haben die nicht
sinnvollen zweite nutzung zugeführt
werden an damen und herren und das wird
uns in diesem fall gelingen indem wir
auch die spitzen laska punkt ab
wegnehmen künftig werden auch kleine
photovoltaikanlagen bis 25 grad voll
einspeisen können das potenzial wird
groben dass es längst überfällig meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren und wir
rannten das flächenpotenzial erweitern
daran scheitert es doch gerade bei der
photovoltaik wir haben zu wenig
geeignete flächen das werden wir tun
indem wir die seiten randstreifen von
200 metern auf 500 metern mehr als
verdoppeln seitenstreifen und autobahn
und schienennetzen wir haben auch dafür
gesorgt dass green land kein tabu mehr
ist sondern dass hier auf geeigneten
grünlandflächen attraktive
entschuldigung adtv also
landwirtschaftliche besser ermöglichen
genau das ist der richtige weg und für
all diejenigen bürgerinnen und bürger
diesen schönen norddeutschland leben und
ein richter haben und da keine
photovoltaik drauf machen haben wir für
gesorgt dass es garten ev gibt dass auch
dort menschen sich ihre anlagen hin
bauen können auch sie sollen an der
energie werden partizipieren genau wo
die menschen liegen denkmalgeschützten
gebäuden lebens das ist energiepolitik
wie sie sein müssen und wir haben auch
die
beteiligung verbessert bisher im
gesetzentwurf stand drin man muss im
gleichen landkreis leben das ist nicht
mehr notwendig auch die menschen zum
beispiel aus der stadtkasse können im
landkreis kassel sich in bürger
energiegenossenschaften engagieren genau
der richtige weg um bürgerbeteiligung zu
verbessern meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren auch bei der wasserkraft
haben wir etwas geschafft da gilt der
status quo und wir haben das wasserkraft
im plural öffentliche interesse gesetzt
auch das ist wichtig meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren lassen sie
mich zum schluss sagen das gilt dieses
alte fußballer sprichwort weiter
gedeutet angelegt nach der reform ist
vor der reform diese position noch
dreieinhalb jahre weiterarbeiten und wir
werden sie noch mit weiteren deutlichen
verbesserungen in diesem bereich
behelligen und zwar als nächstes kommt
dann dass wir hier in diesem bereich
dafür sorgen werden dass mieter strom
deutlich verbessert wird das energy
sharing deutlich verbessert wird und
dass die pv pflicht die photovoltaik
licht für nichtwohngebäude kommt all das
wirkt sie noch erreichen ich freue mich
jetzt schon auf die beratungen aber
einmal kurz durchatmen sollten wir an in
der sommerpause ansonsten bleiben wir
haben bei energie werdende gefahren wird
diese ampel die diesen daten und
glückauf
timon gremmels aus der spd fraktion kein
wunder dass er kassel erwähnt hat in
seinem debattenbeitrag das ist nämlich
seinen wahlkreis 68 kassel wir nähern
uns dem ende dieser debatte aber drei
redner gibt es noch und auch eine
rednerin anja weisgerber aus der
unionsfraktion
wir alle wollen den massiven ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien aber dafür müssen
wir auch die planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren
beschleunigen das wird zur nagelprobe
das wird zur nagelprobe auch für die
ampel regierung und da müssen sie
liefern und ich frage mich an der stelle
es wird immer betont dass jetzt die
erneuerbaren energien und ein teil der
netze im überragenden öffentlichen
interesse lägen aber zur wahrheit gehört
das allein reicht nicht sie müssen auch
einen ausgleich finden zwischen dem
berechtigten interesse des
beschleunigten ausbaus der erneuerbaren
energien und liebe kollegen von den
grünen auch dem artenschutz und diese
ausgleich meine damen und herren der
gelingt ihm eben nicht in der reform des
bundesnaturschutzgesetzes
sie beziehen die artenschutzrechtliche
ausnahmeregelung nur auf die windkraft
es fehlt der 360 grad blick auf alle
erneuerbaren energien es fehlt auch der
einbezug der infrastrukturprojekte in
diesem zusammenhang mit ihrem gesetz
schränken sie den artenschutz massiv ein
ohne einen wirklichen mehrwert für den
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien und
dessen beschleunigung zu erzielen die
experten in der anhörung am montag kamen
zum gleichen ergebnis die antworten der
sachverständigen waren eine ohrfeige für
den vorgelegten gesetzentwurf und damit
auch für das bundesumweltministerium und
deswegen frau kollegin hoffmann bedauere
ich sehr dass ihre ministerin sich heute
entschuldigt hat weil es so einem
wichtigen gesetzespaket wo es auch um
den arten- und umweltschutz geht muss
eine umweltministerin auch bei der
debatte hier im deutschen bundestag vor
ort sein meine
die kritik der sachverständigen war
umfassend das gesetz verzögert die
genehmigungen denn es stehen bislang
noch dringend erforderliche
vollzugshilfe unbestimmte rechtsbegriffe
werden durch ein änderungsantrag nur
teilweise beseitigt eben nicht
ausreichend das gesetz zu war der
wörtliche ausdruck eines
sachverständigen der von der spd benannt
wurde ist ein
arbeitsbeschaffungsprogramm für
rechtsanwälte und fraglich ist auch ob
es mit dem europarecht vereinbar ist
also es können noch klagen und weitere
rechtsunsicherheiten
durch die reform des
bundesnaturschutzgesetzes
drohen so viel zum inhalt und jetzt zum
verfahren die der änderungsantrag zum
gesetz wurde uns am dienstagabend im
umweltausschuss zehn minuten vor der
ausschusssitzung
zugeleitet die anliegen der
sachverständigen haben sie versucht in
dem änderungsantrag zu adressieren wir
konnten es aber gar nicht ausreichend
prüfen ich sage ihnen ganz offen
nach dieser anhörung hätten sie den
gesetzentwurf komplett einpacken müssen
neu machen müssen und sie hätten auch
unsere anliegen die wir jetzt hier im
entschließungsantrag adressieren
aufgreifen müssen meine damen und herren
was sind die anliegen bei der
artenschutzrechtlichen sonderregelung
wie gesagt hätten sie viel größer denken
müssen sie hätten den ausgleich auch
diskutieren müssen bezüglich aller
erneuerbarer energie den ausgleich
zwischen ausbau erneuerbarer energien
und artenschutz sie hätten sich auch mit
dem thema netzausbau und artenschutz
intensiver befassen müssen sie müssen
bezüglich der transformation auch auf
alle infrastrukturprojekte ihren blick
lenken und nicht nur auf die windkraft
und noch etwas haben sie verpasst in
dieser reform des
bundesnaturschutzgesetzes
in dieser reform hätten sie auch eine
regelung in der form reinpacken müssen
bezüglich des ausgleiches für uns ist es
absolut unverständlich warum für den bau
einer freiflächen-photovoltaikanlage
zb auf einer fläche wo vorher ein
maisacker war wo man eigentlich eine
aufwertung danach hat immer noch
zusätzliche ausgleichsflächen notwendig
sind die wiederum der landwirtschaft
auch wieder entzogen werden das ist uns
vollkommen unverständlich auch diese
chance haben sie verpasst dass die
regeln müssen im bundesnaturschutzgesetz
nochmal zum gesamtpaket keine regelungen
sind enthalten zur energieeffizienz
keine regelung zu den speichern sie
konzentrieren sich auf einzelne
erneuerbare energien sie bremsen immer
noch die geothermie auch die biomasse
bezüglich der wasserkraft war sie
einsichtig und haben auf uns gehört dass
es gut bei der solarenergie gibt es nur
einen entschließungsantrag
bezüglich der steuerfreiheit bis 30
kilowatt peak ich nehme ihre zusage auch
ernst dass sie dies regeln werden beim
thema windkraft regen sich hier im bund
letztendlich wie es mit den
abstandsregelung und den flächen
auszusehen hat sie hat sind überhaupt
nicht in dialoge treten mit den ländern
auch in bayern hat man sich deutlich
bewegt so sieht energiewende mit den
bürgern nicht aus ihnen fehlte 30 grad
blick auf alle an eurer energien für
auch eine vorurteilsfreie nutzung aller
energiequellen die denn fehlt der 360
grad blick auch auf alle
infrastrukturprojekte auf die komplette
transformation und sie schauen auch
nicht auf die bürgerinnen und bürger und
die energiepreise wie sich steigen
werden und nicht auf den klimaschutz
vielen dank
anja weisgerber war das aus der
unionsfraktion und meine damen und
herren das ist ja nicht so dass diese
debatte und dieses thema langweilig wäre
aber es gibt noch einen weiteren grund
schön bei uns zu bleiben in den nächsten
stunden und wir wissen nämlich nicht
genau wann es passiert aber es
verdichten sich die hinweise dass der
britische premierminister in johnson
zurücktreten wird sie sehen ihr schon
das bild aus downing street number ten
sobald bei uns johnson vor die tür tritt
sind wir natürlich live dabei einzeln
gehen wir zurück in die regatta und seen
bank bemerkt aus der spd-fraktion hier
am pult das dritte jahr in folge
norditalien wird das wasser rationiert
wegen einer dürre die hälfte der akw in
frankreich es nicht am netz auch weil
die flüsse nicht genug wasser für das
jetzt zehn jahre länger sehen man nichts
bleibt immer noch nichts die welt droht
unbewohnbar zu werden wenn wir unseren
co2 ausstoß nicht drastisch reduzieren
und zwar schleunigst die kinder und
jugendlichen werden deshalb genau
hinschauen was wir hier und heute
beschließen legen wir den turbo ein beim
ausbau der erneuerbaren wir das alles
sozial gerecht zu gestalten werden wir
den klimawandel bremsen und mit einer
wirtschaftlichen perspektive für die
jungen menschen verbinden ich glaube wir
können heute mit der nötigen demut sagen
wir haben verstanden wir kümmern uns um
die zukunft unserer kinder
und das ist unser verdammte pflicht dass
wir das tun damit
die gesetzesänderung war so ehrlich was
wir sein werden nicht alle
zufriedenstellen aber sie sind ein
meilenstein nach 16 jahren
unionsgeführter brems politik wir werden
heute ein neues zeitalter der
energieversorgung einleiten wir werden
heute das land von atom höhe kohle gas
entwickeln zu einem land von wind sonne
und bioenergie meine damen und herren
lassen sich punkte erfolg von 25 bis 35
so eine leistung von zehn gigawatt
installiert wird jedes jahr das nur bei
wind an land allein diese zehn gigawatt
bedeutet strom für 6,6 millionen
haushalte für ein jahr das reicht zum
beispiel für ganz bayern liebe grüße an
herrn söder wir machen tempo
genehmigungsverfahren werden
digitalisiert und vereinfacht ohne den
umwelt- und artenschutz dafür zu
schleifen dem fläche stau lesen wir
indem wir die länder zwei prozent ihrer
flächen für die windenergie ausschreiben
lassen und bei all dem bleibt es dabei
dass die vorgaben zum beispiel
hinsichtlich lärm und schallschutz oder
schattenwurf weiterhin bestehen bleiben
da können sie gerne wie don quichote
immer weiter angst vor den großen bösen
riesen haben und mit ihrem politisch
klapprigen gaul immer drauf los reiten
aber es muss niemand sorge haben dass
bald ein windrad und vorgaben stehen die
abstände bleiben da
jene die wende gelingt es aber nur in
einem gesamtgesellschaftlichen kraftakt
so ehrlich muss wir seien und deshalb
sollen die menschen direkt von der
energiewende profitieren
wer sich also eine private solaranlage
aufs dach setzen und seinen strom
einspeist hat künftig mehr geld denn
anders wir schaffen neue
geschäftsmöglichkeiten landwirte können
künftig beides tun sie können
lebensmittel anbauen auf der einen seite
und gleichzeitig mit solarmodulen über
dem acker strom produzieren und wir
sorgen auch dafür dass die kommunen was
davon haben zum beispiel eine 5 megawatt
anlage mit 13 millionen kilowattstunden
verschafft der kommune 25.000 euro pro
jahr und das ist nur eine einzige anlage
damit kann man zum beispiel lenkert ganz
hervorragend neue spielgeräte für
spielplätze besorgen von stärke den
kommunen profitieren diejenigen
besonders stark die auf die kommunalen
leistungen oft angewiesen sind klein und
mittelverdiener kurzum wir sorgen dafür
dass ein teil der erträge zurück die
bürgerinnen bürger wir wollen bezahlbare
energie für alle den klimaschutz darf
kein privileg für ein paar ist juli
fahren wer den kohlwald sein das schafft
akzeptanz meine damen und herren grund
ist es gerecht
und es ist die deutsche wirtschaft
direkt von windkraft ausbau profitieren
wird bei den geboten von investoren
fließt die co2 bilanz in der produktion
und der einsatz für die crêpes
fachkräftenachwuchs mit 1 damit ein das
stärkt vor allem die heimischen
unternehmen und sorgt für gute jobs hier
vor ort in deutschland auch im norden
all das all das verknüpfen wir
mit der ausschreibung für innovative
speichern dazu zählen auch die
wasserstoffspeicher die aus dem die dem
aus dem strom gewonnen grünen
wasserstoff direkt auch für den winter
einlagern können das könnte helfen wir
haben ja schließlich ein problem mit der
wärmeversorgung im winter all diese
vorhaben sind in zeiten großer energie
sicherheit ein wichtiger beitrag für
mehr sicherheit und innovation meine
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der demokratischen
opposition stimmen sie den
gesetzesentwürfen zu und lassen sie uns
heute wirklich ein starkes signal nach
hause schicken zu den eltern und kindern
wir haben verstanden und jetzt jetzt
legen wir los vielen dank
denkwerk für die spd fraktion also jetzt
tatsächlich der drittletzte redner in
dieser debatte ich verweise noch mal auf
unser bild im bild sobald sich in london
was tut in sachen rücktrittserklärung
boris johnson
bei der vorgang dass er als
parteivorsitzender zurück tritt wohl
schon mehr oder weniger amtlich zu sein
scheint warten wir noch auf dem vorgang
zum premierminister job dann scheint mir
natürlich live nach london 12 hören wir
noch konrad schneider zuerst
vor allen dingen auch mehr freiheit denn
wir dezentralisieren die
energieerzeugung und stärken dadurch die
beteiligungen der bürgerinnen und bürger
wir machen unternehmen und haushalte zu
produzenten und stärken damit auch ihre
unabhängigkeit
wir warten also mehr fortschritt mit
mehr auswirkungen für ganz deutschland
und das freut mich ganz besonders und
daran möchte ich exemplarisch klarmachen
auch für meinen wahlkreis mannheim für
mich zuhause für uns zu hause erster
punkt wir müssen dort zb aus der
kohleverstromung raus da hängt viel
fernwärme dran da ist jetzt in der
fernwärmeversorgung viel potenzial bei
der geothermie der wir hier auch einen
schub verleihen da gibt es im
oberrheingraben riesige schätze zu
bergen das schieben wir an
in der kommune in der kombination aus
neuen möglichkeiten im mieter strom und
speichertechnologien schieben wir auch
das kommunale und das quartiers
quartiers wärmemanagement an der kollege
hat den hat das stichwort der speicher
der wasserstoffspeicher genannter ist
ihn im gange auch da werden kommunen
unabhängiger werden und für baden
württemberg und bayern von besonderer
bedeutung wir stärken auch die kleine
wasserkraft dafür haben die freien
demokraten stark gemacht und dafür haben
wir nebenbei bemerkt auch nicht die
ratschläge aus münchen gebraucht ich
meint mit den energiepolitischen
wendemanöver von markus söder ist rein
gar nichts anzufangen vielleicht kann
man den weg den er damit erzeugt
energetisch nutzen
und was überhaupt das thema tempo und so
weiter betrifft kann ich auch nur noch
einmal nach baden württemberg gucken
liebe freundinnen und freunde von der
cdu die landtagsfraktion die steht dort
beim jedem innovativen projekt ständig
auf der bremse wir laden sie hier heute
ein bei unserem tempo mitzumachen denn
jetzt geht's vorhanden vielen dank
konrad stockmeier aus der fdp-fraktion
unternehmen wird jetzt abschließend
folgen in der debatte franziska kersten
nochmal aus der spd-fraktion wie die
allermeisten redner hier mitglied im
ausschuss für klimaschutz und energie
präsidentin sie hören einer stimme wir
haben wirklich hart verhandelt aber
fast alle haben heute betont dass wir
wirklich wichtig den beschleunigten
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
voranbringen müssen
und herr merz ich kann sie nicht
ersparen dass es war die union dieses in
lange jahre verhindert hat unsere
koalition hat jetzt ein kompromiss
geführt auch zwischen umweltschutz
zwischen klimaschutz und appenzell ich
wie machen wir das wir denken beide
themen zusammen
das neue bundesnaturschutzgesetz
haben wir artenschutzrechtliche vorgaben
wie die mindestabstände zu den
gefährdeten arten beibehalten windräder
werden auch jetzt vorrangig in den
gebieten gebaut wo wir sie da die wir
dafür ausgewiesen wir haben dadurch
endlich
bundeseinheitliche standards
weisgerber
genau weil wir das zusammenbringen wir
haben die nationalen arten
hilfsprogramme angedacht wir werden
ausnahmen wo ausnahmen für den ausbau
der windenergie gemacht werden
investieren wir an anderer stelle in die
den schutz der biodiversität
dafür ist besonders wichtig ist müssen
flächen zur verfügung steht werden und
strukturen und kapazitäten der behörden
vor ort gestärkt gestärkt werden bei den
flächen plädiere ich für eine kaskade
leben zuerst in bau in ausgewiesenen
gebieten erst dann in
landschaftsschutzgebieten und erst zum
schluss in besonders sensible gebiete zu
gehen um die biodiversität nicht zu
stark zu gefährden
genauso wichtig ist die evaluation unser
programm damit wir wissen ob und wie sie
greifen deswegen haben wir zum ersten
mal den begriff evaluation in unser
programm aufgenommen
das ziel muss sein dass kollisionsgefahr
dieter arten mit ihren und ihre
lebensräume wirklich nachweislich und
wirksam geschützt werden und das eu
rechtskonform damit wir eine klagewelle
verhindern
wir haben
gesetzt den weg frei gemacht für den
dringend benötigt schnelleren ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien jetzt müssen wir
natur und artenschutz genauso
beschleunigen
franziska kersten mit brüchiger stimme
weil sie so lange verhandelt haben sagt
sie wir sind die nacht hinein an den
gesetzentwürfen die hier vorliegen die
aussprache ist beendet und wir hören war
es bundestagspräsidentin bis zum knoten
sicheres
abstimmung erklären werde
wie kommen nämlich gleich zu fünf
namentlichen abstimmungen die wir
nacheinander und getrennt durchführen
die abstimmung erfolgen in der west
lobby und für jede abstimmung haben sie
diesmal nur zehn minuten zeit
bitte beachten sie dass die ersten vier
namentlichen abstimmung zu den
gesetzentwürfen jeweils zur
schlussabstimmung erfolgen ich bitte sie
also nach jeder namentlichen abstimmung
wieder in die zweite beratung des
folgenden gesetzentwurfes sowie zur
abstimmung vom beschlussempfehlungen und
entschließungsanträgen wieder in den
plenarsaal zurückzukehren also wenn es
geht nicht oben stehen bleiben an den
ohren sondern wieder zur abstimmung in
den saal kommen nach der jeweiligen
namentlichen abstimmung ich bitte jetzt
die schriftführerin und schriftführer
die vorgesehenen plätze einzunehmen ich
sehe den daumen nach oben die plätze
sind eingenommen
wir kommen zur abstimmung über den von
der bundesregierung eingebrachten
gesetzentwurf zur sofort maßnahmen für
einen beschleunigten ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien und weiteren
maßnahmen im stromsektor
es liegt eine erklärung nach § 31 der
geschäftsordnung dazu vor der ausschuss
für klimaschutz und energie empfiehlt
unter buchstaben a und b seiner
beschluss empfehlungen auf drucksachen
2580 neu und
2656 den gesetzentwurf der
bundesregierung auf drucksachen
1630 und
1979 in der ausschuss fassung anzunehmen
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
gesetzentwurf in der ausschuss fassung
zustimmen wollen um das handzeichen
das sind die fraktionen der spd bündnis
90 die grünen und die fdp fraktion
gegenstimmen das sind die fraktion die
linke die cdu csu fraktion und die fdp
fraktion enthaltungen sehe ich nicht der
gesetzentwurf ist damit in zweiter
beratung angenommen dritte beratung und
namentliche schlussabstimmung
die plätze sind besetzt ich eröffne die
erste namentliche schlussabstimmung über
den gesetzentwurf dafür haben sie zehn
minuten zeit und ich bitte sie nach
dieser abstimmung wieder in den saal zu
kommen
so meine damen und herren das ist recht
sportlich muss man sagen zehn minuten
für die namentliche abstimmung sie sehen
das
rennen hätte ich fast gesagt habe ist
natürlich unangemessen als ausdruck aber
es geht doch jetzt relativ zügig mit den
abgeordneten die sich aus dem plenarsaal
in die west lobby bewegen da haben wir
auch bilder für sie vorbereitet damit
sie sehen wie die ersten abgeordneten
ihre stimmkarten schon gleich einwerfen
in die abstimmungs ohren wie gesagt zehn
minuten und es geht im moment um den um
den gesetzentwurf zu sofortmaßnahmen für
einen beschleunigten ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien und weiterer
maßnahmen im stromsektor die drucksache
zu diesem gesetzentwurf mit 276 seiten
lang da jetzt alle punkte heraus zu
fischen würde ein bisschen zu weit
führen auch angesichts der weiteren
themen die wir haben vielleicht nur ein
paar stichworte dazu also zum einen wird
in diesem gesetzentwurf festgehalten
dass das ausbauziel für 20 30 angehoben
wird und zwar auf einen anteil
erneuerbarer energien von mindestens 80%
dann soll das die inländischen
stromerzeugung bereits im jahr 2035
nahezu treibhausgas neutral sein es geht
hier
um außerdem beschleunigte verfahren
wenn es um den ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien geht es geht darum dass bürger
einige energiegesellschaften weniger
bürokratisch agieren müssen
beziehungsweise deren ansehen was wind
und solarprojekte angeht weniger
bürokratisch
weniger und grill niedrigere
bürokratische hürden haben die förderung
der solarenergie ist wird noch mal
beschleunigt während wir den früheren
aussenminister heiko maas im vest lobby
sehen und auch sehen wie sich das ganze
da knubbelt aber es gibt das ganze wird
ihr ziel wie gesagt noch gut sieben
minuten gehen dann wird der nächste
gesetzentwurf aufgerufen dann wenn wir
dasselbe prozedere hier haben aber sie
haben auch gesehen meine damen und
herren das sich auch an anderer stelle
in europa etwas tut nämlich in london wo
der rücktritt die rücktrittserklärung
von premierminister johnson erwartet
wird und deswegen im nutzen wir die
gelegenheit wo hier gerade so friedlich
schiedlich abgestimmte wird für einen
kurzen sprung gehen unser studio und zu
marc stein